bonjour noël où les merci d'être avec
nous cet après midi sur rt france alors
henri konan bédié chef de l'opposition
en côte d'ivoire devrait devait tenir
une conférence de presse après ces
résultats mais des forces de l'ordre
sont placés tout autour de chez lui
l'ont tâches actuelles montrent
s'exprimer votre réaction à cette
actualité
narcy beaucoup de non recevoir le monde
en se voir si votre enfant est
effectivement un point de presse était
prévue une forme de croix qui peut-être
que vous aviez jours de mission du
président henri konan bédié
malheureusement est en train d'être
perdue de fortement à un mandat
d'arrestation du président henri
konan-bédié et cela nous a plu lançons
un appel à toute la population de sortir
massivement aux constituants beaucoup
mieux autour du président henri konan
bédié parce que alassane dramane
ouattara
ce programme président de la côte
d'ivoire la crosse d'un poids et nous le
peuple de co2 vol peuple souverain de
côte d'ivoire a dit non maintenant en
respectant le mot d'ordre de la henri
konan bédié et qui a fait que le taux de
participation aux élections étaient les
10% selon les observateurs et fumant
hilaire utah même du terrain alors
alassane ouattara élu président pour la
troisième fois consécutive
comment les résultats sont accueillis
dans l'ensemble du pays quels sont les
retours ce que vous avez les retours que
nous avons fait que la population
trouverait le peuple souverain de côte
d'ivoire ne se reconnaît pas dans cette
élection qu'elle ne reconnaît pas avoir
avoir vécu une élection libre juste et
équitable et inclusive en côte d'ivoire
en cette année 2010 et sur un
gouvernement de transition et a mis en
place à le président henri konan bédié
voilà d'où l'attaqué a seulement depuis
la rivière jusqu'à ce jour la résidente
de notre leader est en train d'être
attaquée et tous les leaders de
l'opposition avec vous parliez du
de ce gouvernement de transition mis en
place par henri konan-bédié quel sera
son rôle à ce gouvernement de transition
le rôle du gouvernement de transition
qui devra organiser des élections j'ai
plus libre conclut ville temps de parole
très vite on connaît le peuple souverain
de quoi dubois ville une transition
paisible et un climat de sécurité en
côte d'ivoire et justement vous avez
appelé tout à l'heure les ivoiriens à
manifester à sortir dans la rue pour
manifester contre l'élection d'alassane
ouattara est ce que vous ne craignez pas
de nouvelles violences au sein même de
votre pays la violence ont commencé dès
l'annoncé de la candidature de suez à la
fin dramane ouattara la violence
continue à la tortue de s'imposer vaille
que vaille pour un résultat des
dispositions les élections parce qu'il
lui même les témoins de ce qui se
passait témoin le résultat de j quand on
est que le ratio qui est habilité à
donner les résultats provisoires n'a pas
eu la possibilité de consolider ses
résultats parce qu'il n'ya pas eu
d'élection sur l'étendue du territoire
ivoirien
il ya juste une mascarade d'élection et
le peuple souverain de côte d'ivoire
guinot à cette confiture ou la énième
fois
quelles sont les solutions pour vous
pour tenter d'essayer d'apaiser les
tensions
la solution pour nous c'est de demander
à monsieur alassane dramane ouattara qui
a déjà épuisé ses deux mandats selon
notre constitution de revenus dans la
république de donner de son tour donné
pour revenir dans la république pour
discuter avec les alliés d'y est pour
que nous puissions trouver un consensus
au pire des cas de libérer purement et
simplement le poète résidentiel parce
que nous ne le reconnaissons pas comme
président de la république de côte
d'ivoire
merci beaucoup noël venait d'avoir été
avec nous cet après midi sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes la présidente de
l'union des femmes du parti démocratique
de côte d'ivoire merci beaucoup